it's my distinct pleasure to introduce
Arianna Huffington journalist
extraordinaire founder of Huff Post I
sort of started in my day on HuffPost
sometimes I feel otter of 15
best-selling books including most
recently the sleep revolution Time
Magazine's 100 most influential Forbes
most powerful women board member to uber
onyx global citizen just capital feels
super hard driving and feels like oh my
god how do you manage all of this in 24
hours and yet we find ourselves here
talking about her latest venture which
is founded in 2016
called thrive Kobol corporation a
corporate and consumer well Billy being
and productivity platform to help us
change the way we work and live
welcome Arianna thank you so much where
does that hard-charging Forbes most
powerful times 100 most influential get
to talking about sleep well this is a
fantastic question to start with
because it's at the heart of everything
we are doing a tribe which is ending the
delusion that we've been living under
really since the first Industrial
Revolution so for decades that in order
to succeed in order to achieve amazing
things like everybody here is doing we
need to be always on we need to never
stop to unplug and recharge and what is
interesting about that is that we now
have overwhelming data scientific
findings that prove that the opposite is
true that in fact when we take time to
recharge we operate from a deep
more productive more effective more
creative part of ourselves and we
achieve much more in a more sustainable
way and what is interesting you know you
and I come from ancient civilizations
India and ancient Greece you know knew
that so if you go back to the ancient
wisdom of our cultures they knew that
you know I mean I as you know I engaged
my favorite country I started at
Shantiniketan University 117 and the
backward agita makes it very clear that
there is a higher life where you
actually operate from resources that
otherwise you don't even know you have
but somewhere despite of being in
Shantiniketan when you were 17 I think I
heard something about hitting a head on
exactly and caused this awakening
absolutely I kind of basically bought
into their collective delusion which is
really hard to avoid if you're a type-a
personality like everybody here is I'm
sure and everybody on stage let's admit
it
so I absolutely bought into all that and
so two years into building the
Huffington Post being a divorced mother
of two teenage daughters which is has
its own problems attached I collapsed
from burnout sleep deprivation
exhaustion hit my head on my desk broke
my cheekbone and that was really the
beginning of my new awakening that led
to launching thrive and being here how
long did it take from that awakening to
really you know change habits and be
that person who's now you know has
bestselling books on this topic so you
know I'm a kind of research freak so I
started studying everything delving into
the latest science and the entire thrive
global platform is based on the
scientific knowledge that we grow and
change through micro steps he doesn't
happen
overnight it's small incremental daily
changes so that's what happened with me
in every aspect of life from the obvious
you know sleep meditation but also
what's happening in our minds because
very often it's this what I call the
obnoxious roommate living in our head
you know that negative voice we women
have it worse guys you know self doubt
and questioning everything that we need
to we need to address so doing all that
eliminates a lot of the energy leaks so
makes more energy available to us to
simply get things done and achieve
groundbreaking things okay so here you
are with your awakening and your
research and you're armed with it but
you're starting a company like a lot of
folks here small companies which are
fast growth did it worry you that maybe
this is not good for business this is
you know good for the person that the
company may need to be hard-charging how
does the business leaders in this room
make a change within their organizations
so being hard-charging is absolutely the
necessary way to get anything done
Yardley Poe who is here who heads
product for thrive global and I call it
having a high metabolism we don't want
to hire anybody who does not have a high
metabolism we don't want to hire anybody
who is not hard-charging
and at the beginning there are some
people who thought oh this company is
about thriving I can join and chill
under a mango tree no no we wrong
company
no we just believe and we have the data
to prove it when I say believe it's not
really the right word that when
hard-charging individuals then take some
time to unplug and recharge they are
going to be much more effective when
they return hard-charging and that's
really the key
and you know that because ever I mean
I'm so happy to be speaking to an
audience which is so much about getting
things done achieving and knowing that
you need a focus to be able to do that
and I think what is key here is also our
relationship with technology because we
are all a little addicted assists a few
people who can't stop looking at their
phones let me just tell you something
that's perfectly fine but don't fool
yourself into thinking you're we are
also listening to us you are making a
choice that clearing emails or text
right now is more important I totally
get it were not offended I just want to
make it clear that multitasking is a
myth you cannot do two things at once
that involves mental energy yeah you can
wash the dishes and listen to a podcast
but you can't do two things that require
cognitive energy that's why I thrive
global we don't allow devices during
meetings because you know this
incredibly long and unproductive
meetings when everybody the minute there
is a moment of boredom calls to their
phone
you know they pretend that they're
taking notes but you know they're not so
we basically say listen if you have
something more important to do go do it
if you're here just be a hundred percent
present and so there's an enormous
amount of stuff that we can bring to our
companies to be able to be hard-charging
in a sustainable way building a company
is not a sprint it's a marathon so we
need to do it for the long haul you have
termed this to kind of very interesting
terms you describe 2017 as the year of
the Great Awakening where we became
aware of what technology is doing to us
and 2018 as a great reckoning what's
happening how did we get here well as
you know everybody here is involved in
building great products or running great
companies so you know until 2017 in
speaking generally
we were completely enthralled with
technology we did not really look at the
unintended consequences there was a case
certain kind of triumphalism around tech
2017 was the year of Great Awakening
when we also saw that even though
there's so much to celebrate around the
role of tech in our lives there also
unintended consequences and they have to
do largely with the way technology is
infringing on our humanity so we need to
establish rules of the road we need to
establish sacred boundaries and I love
the tick nut hon you know the great
Buddhist man climb that it has never
been easier to run away from ourselves
that's kind of a really interesting
thing to talk about because this morning
I talked about what we are doing in
digital being right most of the
platforms have announced some
investments where they're giving users
more control over their tech and we're
expecting users to choose what they can
and how much they use are we doing
enough well first of all I think the
launch of digital well-being was
fantastic you know I was there
applauding I loved seeing your CEO in
front of a screen that said Joe Meaux
the joy of missing out I think it was
one of those great moments in tech when
a great tech leader acknowledges the
responsibility of tech to actually
produce products that help people manage
their relationship with technology in a
way that improves the quality of their
lives and what I love about that is that
it is clearly good for business also
because in the end if if your consumers
recognize that you are adding value to
their lives their loyalty will only
increase and I think this is an ongoing
pursuit I don't think there will ever be
a day when we can say we've done enough
we are done I think as
showed you know bringing a screen time
on iOS which helps you manage your
relationship with technology more and
more tech companies now are entering the
field and thrive launched an app for
Android so anybody here on Android can
download it it's called the thrive up
and it can help you put your phone in
thrive mode let's say you're having
dinner with your children or your
girlfriend or your boyfriend and you
don't want to be disrupted Eve i text
you I'll get a text but here in thrive
mode until such-and-such a time which I
love because it also changes the
cultural norm right now we sort of
congratulate people for being always on
for answering texts immediately we need
to change that we need people to say hey
you know Ariana has a real sense of
priority she really takes some time to
be undistracted when she's doing
something that matters and the other
thing the app does it gives you a
dashboard every day of your social media
a game and general app consumption and
it can help you set limits if you so
decide let's say the app shows that you
spend two hours on Instagram and it asks
if you want to limit it if you say yes I
want to spend an hour and a half it will
give you notifications and a 10 hour and
a half it cuts you out tough love so
Apple has put it on the operating system
for iOS users which is great
they don't have the Thrive mode but they
have everything else so again I think
tech for good tech that helps us improve
the quality of our lives is just a great
opportunity for any developers in the
room to pursue in the future and yet I'm
sure everybody is sitting here or
measuring what's my engagement metric
how many minutes is somebody spending in
my app feels a little scary that
people are going to get out of their app
how should we measure that these folks
in this room how should they measure
what success absolutely we're all going
to be manager measuring consumer
engagement at thrive obviously we
measure consumer engagement on a media
platform on our different social
platforms the question is what are they
doing while they're engaging with you is
what they're doing while they're
engaging with you improving their life
or diminishing their life and also are
you becoming so addictive that other
parts of their lives are suffering you
know their relationships with their
loved ones their relationship with
themselves these are the questions to
ask and the one thing I can guarantee is
that these things are not in opposition
to your business metrics because in the
end I'm convinced that the people who
will win the future are the people who
add value to consumers lives often ahead
of what consumers think they need one of
my favorite marketing stories is Henry
Ford you know when they who said that if
I had asked my customers what they
wanted they would have told me a faster
horse instead I gave them a car so we
all sometimes give consumer something
they may not even fully know they want
but if it improves their lives
that's an incredible source of loyalty
that leads us really well into something
you and I just caught up a couple
minutes ago and you said how about
teaching empathy and other things
through apps and games and you have
talked a lot about human centered design
can you talk a little bit about that yes
we are all fascinated with the AI and
the growth of AI and KY fully recently
wrote a very interesting book predicting
that two thirds of jobs are going to be
eliminated by AI but the jobs are going
to be at a premium our jobs that require
purely human qualities like creativity
empathy compassion love these are the
qualities that we humans are unbeaten at
so in the war for talent these are the
qualities that are going to be at a
premium so how do we cultivate them so
my kind of plea with anybody here with a
developer is to to build products that
cultivate human empathy and I think this
is going to be an incredible business
opportunity because empathy is going to
be a greater and greater requirement for
any interactions in companies in order
to build successful teams you need you
need human beings who know how to
empathize with each other and so if you
can create games that can teach empathy
whether it's to kindergarteners or to
people at any age it would be an
incredible benefit and if anybody has
any such idea please let me know because
we would love to help support it help
fund it help amplify it basically we are
in the business not just of building our
own company but helping that whole
ecosystem that produces tech4good that
improves the quality of our lives and
taking that one step further one way I
suppose to be empathetic is to respect
your users time and you've also talked
about building more respectful
experiences how do you know you're
respecting your users time the question
is is your user using your app or your
game or whatever intentionally or are
they just using it in a compulsive way
without getting any benefit at the end
of it you know that when you have that
feeling of oh my god I can't believe I
spent 40 minutes on candy crush
and and and you and you have that kind
of sinking feeling well that's not
something you want associated with your
program long term you know short term
you may get a benefit from it but I
think you know may not have superhero
movies for coders and developers but I
think maybe you should make some
superhero movies for coders and
developers who are actually producing
products that are helping people invest
their time well because that's all we
have you know I've always been
fascinated by philosophy and the meaning
of life you know ever since I was a
little girl and and in the end you know
how we spend our time is how we spend
our life it's the cumulative result of
all these daily decisions who make I
love that how we spend our time is how
we spend our life so maybe we you know
we started with your Great Awakening by
literally hitting your head on a table
and we went into trying to figure out
what everybody can do from a business
responsibility perspective I want to
bring it back to you this has been an
amazing journey in both first of all
thank you for applying your incredible
journalistic mindset to this problem
it's been an incredible journey in in
learning this what were the surprises
for you individually in getting to this
place were the drawers that did you slip
off the bandwagon as they say and did
you have to climb back in well I I feel
so passionate about this topic that you
know I left the Huffington Post two
years ago to launch thrive and frankly I
never ever thought I would do that
because half first was like a Fairchild
you know two daughters and Hospice but I
wanted to to go beyond just writing and
speaking about these topics and actually
do something that helps people go from
perhaps knowing what they want to do to
actually doing it and what brought me to
general Ismet
beginning was that desire we all have to
reduce human suffering and there is a
lot of human suffering in the world that
we we cannot really easily reduce you
know when you read the stories of
refugee children or children separated
from their parents or violence
everywhere but this is an incredible
cause of human suffering that we can
change simply by changing beliefs
because once we eliminate the belief
which is unbelievably prevalent that all
successful people do it by being always
on and sacrificing everything else to
that cause once you eliminate that
delusion we are going to be eliminating
an incredible cause of disease of bad
decisions and unnecessary mental health
problems so that's an incredible cause
and that's really the very ambitious
cause of thrive and we do it through our
work with corporations and we do it
through the media platform but what we
have found is that the most effective
thing on the media platform is not the
data we collect we collect all the
latest science on these topics but what
moves hearts and minds is the stories of
very successful people in the arena who
are living their lives differently as a
result of the wrong wake-up calls or
epiphanies all very different but having
a similar point to my own epiphany and
actually one of your colleagues Philip
Schindler the chief business officer at
Google had his own moment of Epiphany
that he wrote about on thrive which I
loved which was that he came from a trip
and he has young children and he told
his children dad is taking to the
playground and his five-year-old said to
him oh no can't the babysitter take us
and he asked why and his son said
because when you're in the playground
you're always on your phone so that was
his moment of Epiphany when he
decided I'm busy I travel a lot when I'm
going to be with my children I'm going
to be with my children
and I'm not gonna be on my phone and
then after he wrote about it he told me
what an impact it had in his own org and
I know it had an incredible impact among
people who simply admired him people
need permission to make these little
changes because there is a fear that if
I get my foot off the gas for even five
minutes I'm not going to be able to
succeed it's a very deep-seated fear and
so when we collect the stories of very
successful people Jeff Bezos were out on
thrive that he sleeps for eight hours a
night because he says it improves his
decision-making and he analyzed his
decision-making and he wrote that when
he sleeps for less his decision-making
is five to twenty percent less good and
the piece went crazy viral and so we
bring in people in the arena and have
them write about what makes the most
effective it's really I like to out very
successful people and they're good
things they do because we've heard so
much about very successful people
bragging you know like Acadia the other
extreme which is a teachable moment is
Elon Musk
you know he's totally captive of this
delusionary belief that he has to do
everything himself he has to sleep under
his desk he cannot see his children but
we see the result of that we see that he
tweets in the middle of the night that
he got the funding to take Tesla private
which was not true which led to an SEC
investigation which led to him having to
step down as chairman being fine twenty
million dollars not a very good decision
you know we have him on I'm saying that
Allah villain mosque I think he's
brilliant and a great visionary but he's
also doing an incredible service now by
demonstrating the delusion of the way
he's working and that may be just an
incredible give to humanity
I wrote an open letter to him saying all
that out saying you know the way you're
working is unscientific you know you
claim to really have developed and you
have a new way to manage energy - for
cars what about managing energy for
Humanity and that's why this is such an
exciting time well no wonder you're so
coachable managing energies for cars
versus managing images for Humanity the
meme in the valley which you are well
aware is that sleep is for the weak
yes and you have picked that as your
cornerstone of well-being can you talk
about why sleep yeah we actually have
eight pathways broken down into micro
steps and sleep is one there isn't why
there is so much focus on sleep is
because for so many decades it's been so
dismissed and held in contempt and yet
all the science makes it very clear that
it's a foundation of health not just of
our physical health but our brain health
and we now know and a lot of that
research was done near by here at
Stanford where the first scientific
sleep Center was founded only in 1970 so
it's a relatively young science but we
now see that the way our culture has has
been contemptuous of sleep has actually
led to tremendous problems and bad
decisions and health outcomes including
heart disease diabetes Alzheimer's
because the bottom line is that unless
you have a genetic mutation and want one
and a half percent of the population
does and you don't need a lot of sleep
I'm sure there are people here who don't
and that's great and you know it you can
also be tested but I know that if I have
three or four hours sleep it's not
enough so the majority of us need seven
to nine hours I'm an eight-hour girl and
when I get my eight hours it's like
bring it on whatever the challenge
whatever I can
and also I'm not robbed of the joy of
life one of the things that I know when
I'm sleep deprived I can still be
transactional we can still go through
the motions of our day but something is
missing and I don't want that spark to
miss because as far as we know that's
our only life although reincarnation is
a very good possibility and I just don't
want to just get things done I want to
experience the joy and the gratitude of
the Father that I'm doing something I
love and I believe in and how what a
blessing that is okay so given that this
is where you find yourself what's next
for you so what's next as you know
thrive global is the name of the company
not just because you could get the URL
this is you know this is a global crisis
and the solution is global so we
launched our first international launch
was in India we launched in partnership
with The Times of India and I love what
we are doing there in the middle of what
is a mental health crisis especially
among Millennials who are particularly
addicted to their phones and we launched
in my homeland in Greece and well we
launched in Australia we are going to
China and we are launching around the
world and in every big culture we are
customizing what we are offering with
the culture of the country because there
is such amazing wisdom in India in China
in Japan and I think it's so important
to bring everything we are doing and
integrated with the culture and the
wisdom of the region and and for me I'm
just so incredibly grateful when people
write and tell their story so I want to
invite you to tell your stories because
that's how we learn from each other and
whether it's stories of wake-up calls
like mine or Philippe Schindler's or
whether there are stories of your own
life hacks and what you do to be most
effective please share them with the
world is just an incredible service and
also I hardly would not forgive me if I
didn't say that we are hiring we have
opened an office in in San Francisco our
headquarters is in New York and we are
we really want to grow our product and
engineering team very fast because of so
many projects in line and I'm also for
the women in the room I'm also thrilled
to say that we have a head of product
with a woman in Yardley and a CTO in
Sheryl Paul who is also a woman who just
joined us from Salesforce so I'm also
I'm very happy to recruit men let me
make that very clear but I also think
it's an amazing time to be a woman in
product and engineering look at you and
and it's it's it's great to be building
a team that we hope is going to add a
lot of value to people's lives
well you have some super creative people
I know you're trying to recruit them but
besides recruiting them if there's one
message you want to leave them with what
would that be so my message is that you
are the architects of the future and
what you choose to do and where you
choose to put your own creativity and
your own imagination and is going to
change the world so it's really
incredibly important and whether you're
running businesses developing or coding
or anything at all this is a pivotal
moment the decisions you make every day
the products we build the businesses we
build are going to affect dramatically
the way we live and the world we create
and I'm not at all worried about AI
because
I may become more intelligent than we
are but it will never become more loving
more compassionate more empathetic or my
career or more creative that's our
competitive edge
let's cultivate it
[Music]
thank you so much for sharing your
wisdom with us today I hope every one of
us will take this at least for me I
think that I will remember
am i transacting or am I actually
feeling the joy of what I am doing with
gratitude and can you please write about
it yes okay she said that in front of
many witnesses so we're going to hold it
accountable and what was it like having
here on stage for 30 minutes two women
with accents right with that give Ariana
a very very big hand
[Music]